moving to Russia now the country is
being condemned for a new wave of
missile strikes it plunged much of
Ukraine's Capital Into Darkness
yesterday's attacks on Ukraine's power
grid caused one of Keith's biggest
outages in what has been nine months now
of War at least 10 people were killed in
strikes across the country the president
of Ukraine is calling this energy Terror
you see on your screens Chris let's say
is in key Chris good morning
good morning Errol from a wintry cave
where Vladimir Putin continues to attack
the critical electrical grid now the
government has set up these tents to
keep residents warm and give them a
place to charge their phones and these
are the lucky ones who have survived
with the latest strikes cars at this
intersection completely burnt out Russia
appears determined to bomb Ukraine Into
the Dark Ages knocking out power in
streets homes even hospitals surgeons at
the Kiev Hart Institute operate with
flashlights and without running water at
this apartment building in the capital a
17 year old girl was among those killed
when a Russian missile Came Crashing
through the roof Victoria and her mother
Tatiana have come home to What's Left
you've lost everything what are you
gonna do
it's so so hard she cries if you're
seeing this please help us why are
kindergarten schools and residential
buildings attacked this is not strategic
infrastructure like millions of
ukrainians she's now left in the dark
freezing cold as the country's last
three fully functional nuclear power
plants had to be disconnected from the
grid speaking to the U.N president
zielinski denounced Russia for crimes
against humanity the situation is
critical says the director of Ukraine's
biggest energy provider people are
suffering true that is not a convenient
place to be true in some cases people
lost friends relatives kids through but
I think that the spirit is very strong
sorry these attacks backfiring are they
actually strengthening Ukrainian
solidarity I'm sure I'm sure I'm sure
now the integer Minister says that most
of Ukraine's nuclear power plants should
be reconnected to the grid by this
evening but that does not include
Europe's biggest nuclear power plant in
zapparesia which remains under Russian
occupation and has been shelled
repeatedly Michelle
outrageous and heartbreaking Chris
lifesay in Ukraine thank you